>> Sean: TODAY IS THE 31ST
ANNIVERSARY OF HIS RADIO SHOW
AND THE DAV NETWORK, JOINING IS
NOW FROM THE ABBEY BECOME A
SOUTHERN COMMAND IS IN THE ONE
YEARS.
I THINK --
>> IS FLAT OUT AMAZING GOOD
KNOW, THE TIME HAS RAISED BY ON
CERTAIN THINGS AND OTHER DAYS
IT'S JUST BEEN SLOW AND SLOPPY
BUT MAN, AND LIBELOUS.
WE'LL LIVE.
IT'S SUCH A GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO TALK ABOUT
THESE THINGS THAT REALLY MATTER
TO THE FUTURE OF THE COUNTRY
WITH SO MANY MILLIONS OF PEOPLE.
IT'S REALLY BEEN AN HONOR AND
IT'S ONGOING.
I MEAN, THERE'S STILL NOTHING I
DO THAT I GET MORE ENJOY
ENJOYMENT OUT OF THAN THIS.
ALSO APPEARING ON FOX.
I'VE BEEN VERY BLESSED TO BE
INVITED HERE BY YOU AND I CAN'T
THANK YOU ENOUGH FOR HAVING ME
ON.
>> Sean: 'S BRUSH, I THINK
YOU'VE GOT THE GREATEST
COMPLIMENT EVER FROM MARY
NOWLIN.
I THINK IT WAS AFTER THE CLINTON
YEARS SHE GOES, I DON'T KNOW HOW
WE WOULD'VE SURVIVED BUT YOU
BEING THERE EVERY DAY.
I THINK A LOT OF CONSERVATIVES,
INCLUDING MYSELF, FEEL THAT WAY.
>> WELL, IT'S BEEN A LOT OF TIME
BUT IT'S INTERESTING IF YOU GO
BACK, IT STARTED IN 1988, AND IN
1988, THERE WAS NOTHING THAT THE
THREE NETWORKS AND THE TWO BIG
NEWSPAPERS AND CNN.
IN TERMS OF CONSERVATISM IN THE
MEDIA, IT WOULD PROBABLY BE THE
NATIONAL REVIEW, WILLIAM
BUCKLEY'S MAGAZINE, BOB TERRELL,
THAT WAS IT.
BUT NOW THERE IS MORE MEDIA AND
FOR FOUR YEARS, THERE WASN'T
ANYTHING.
IT WAS ME AND ME ON TV.
THEN YOU GOT YOUR SHOW AND OTHER
CONSERVATIVES STARTED TO APPEAR
IN RADIO ENGINE AND IT JUST
BUILT AND BUILT AND FINALLY FOX
GOES ON THE AIR IN 1996 BUT
DURING THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN, NOT
TO BRAG, AND THE MARY MATALIN
WAS RIGHT.
THERE WAS NOTHING ELSE EXCEPT US
ON THE RADIO DOING BATTLE WITH
THAT AND IT'S AMAZING TO THINK
BACK TO ELDER THINGS THAT HAVE
HAPPENED AND WHERE WE ARE.
I PLAYED A CLIP OF MYSELF TODAY
ON CHARLIE ROSE.
IN 1992, THIS IS 27 YEARS AGO,
AND I'M TALKING, HE WANTS TO
KNOW WHY I THINK RADICAL
ENVIRONMENTALISTS ARE ACTUALLY
SOCIALIST AND HE THINKS I'M FULL
OF IT.
HE'S HAVING A LOT OF FUN WITH
ME, HE'S LAUGHING.
THIS IS THE DAYS WHEN THESE
PEOPLE USE TO INVITE ME ON THEIR
SHOWS WHEN THEY THOUGHT IT WAS
HARMLESS AND FUN LIKE A CIRCUS
ACT TO HAVE ON.
BUT THESE PEOPLE HAD NO IDEA OF
THE SERIOUSNESS THAT WE BROUGHT
TO THIS BUT 26, 27 YEARS AGO,
AND HERE TODAY, IN THAT DEBATE
LAST NIGHT, ANDREW YANG, I
THINK, I CAN'T BELIEVE THIS HAS
NOT GOTTEN MORE REACTION.
ANDREW YANG SAID WE ARE TOO
LATE.
WE DON'T HAVE TIME ANYMORE.
IT'S TIME TO MOVE OUR PEOPLE TO
HIGHER GROUND.
TALKING ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE.
TO HIGHER GROUND.
STOP AND THINK ABOUT THAT.
MOVE OUR PEOPLE TO HIGHER
GROUND.
JAY ANSLEY THEN CAME OUT AND
ADMITTED WHAT ALL OF THIS
CLIMATE CHANGE IS.
HE SAID EVERY PROGRESSIVE
LIBERAL ISSUE IS WRAPPED UP IN
CLIMATE CHANGE AND IT IS.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS WHAT ALLOWS
THEM TO POISON THE MINDS OF
YOUNG KIDS, TO BLAME PEOPLE FOR
CAUSING A PROBLEM AND THEN
OFFERING THEM REDEMPTION.
MAKE THEM FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE
MEANING IN THEIR LIVES BY SAVING
THE PLANET.
IT'S GONE TO THE POINT, THESE
PEOPLE ACTUALLY HAVE CONVINCED
PEOPLE THAT WE CAN CHANGE THE
WEATHER.
THAT WE CAN CHANGE THE
TEMPERATURE.
AND NONE OF THIS IS TRUE.
IT'S A LITERAL LUNACY AND
INSANITY THAT HAS BECOME
MAINSTREAM ON THAT SIDE OF THE
AISLE AND THEY ARE GOING DOWN
THE TUBES WITH IT.
IT'S REMARKABLE.
I WATCH THE DEBATE LAST NIGHT.
I'M ON THE FLOOR LAUGHING
THROUGH MUCH OF IT.
YOU KNOW IT'S BAD WHEN
RAHM EMANUEL HAS TO GO ON TV
TODAY AND CRITICIZE THESE PEOPLE
FOR BEING NUTS WITH THIS AGENDA.
I MEAN, GLORIA MARGE ON CNN,
WHERE WAS THE INSPIRATION?
THERE ISN'T ANY INSPIRATION.
PEOPLE NEED TO UNDERSTAND HOW
THE DEMOCRATS SEE AMERICANS.
THIS IS THE THING THAT JUST
BOGGLES MY MIND.
THEY LOOK OUT OVER THIS
LANDSCAPE, THEY SEE NOTHING BUT
SUFFERING.
THEY DON'T SEE ANYBODY OTHER
THAN THE VICTIMS OF THIS,
VICTIMS OF THAT.
THEN THEY POSITION THEMSELVES
AND THE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO FIX
IT AND YET EVEN WITH THE OTHER
PEOPLE, US, WHO HAVE CAUSED ALL
OF THIS, THERE ISN'T ANYTHING
THEY TALK ABOUT THAT INVOLVES
IMPROVING LIFE.
THEY DO NOT OFFER ANYBODY
ANYTHING UPLIFTING AND THEY
HAVEN'T PREEMPTED A GROUP OF
VOTERS THAT EVEN THINGS
UPLIFTING.
THEIR VOTER GROUP IS MIRED IN
ALL TYPES OF MISERY, INJUSTICE,
TO THE POINT THEY ARE COVERING
UP GEORGE WASHINGTON MURALS IN
SAN FRANCISCO.
RATHER THAN CLEANING THE HUMAN
OFF THE STREETS OUT THERE.
IT'S AN AMAZING THING TO SEE HOW
THIS IS ALL TRANSFORMING.
YOUR GUESTS JUST BEFORE ME ON
THIS SHOW, STOP AND THINK OF IT.
THREE YEARS AGO, NOBODY THOUGHT
THE DONALD DRUNKEN WHIMPERED I'M
TALKING ABOUT IN THE MAINSTREAM.
THE MEDIA, THE WASHINGTON
ESTABLISHMENT, NOBODY THOUGHT HE
COULD WIN.
TONIGHT, NOBODY THINKS ANYBODY
ON THAT DEMOCRATIC DEBATE STAGE
COULD WIN.
IN JUST THREE YEARS, WE HAVE
GONE FROM A CANDIDATE THAT
EVERYBODY WAS LAUGHING AT HIM
THINKING HAD NO PRAYER AND WAS
AN EVEN SERIOUS ABOUT WINNING TO
NOW, NOBODY ON THE DEMOCRATIC
SIDE, THEY ARE ASKING
MICHELLE OBAMA TO GET IN AND
SAVE US.
IF THEY ARE DOING THAT, NOBODY
THEY ARE RUNNING NOW HAS A
SLIGHT CHANCE OR EVEN A PRAYER.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU.
MY BUDDY BILL CUNNINGHAM, YOU
KNOW BILL FROM CINCINNATI, RADIO
TALK SHOW HOST, GREAT GUY,
FUNNY.
HE IS TELLING ME THEY WILL LINE
UP AT SIX IN THE MORNING TO SEE
THE PRESIDENT.
I WAS --
YOU WERE GRACIOUS ENOUGH.
YOU INVITED ME TO YOUR WEDDING.
THE ONLY PEOPLE YOU SEE LINED UP
AROUND THE BLOCK FOR LONG
PERIODS OF TIME USUALLY CAN SING
WELL, PLAY PIANO, OR GUITAR,
EXPLAIN THE TRUMP PHENOMENON
VERSUS WHAT WE ARE SINGING HERE.
>> WELL, THE TRUMP PHENOMENON
EVENING, ECHOES BACK I THINK TO
THE DIFFERENCES THAT THE
DEMOCRATS AND THE PRICE THAT WE
HAVE IN THE WAY WE SEE THE
COUNTRY.
WE CONSERVATIVES, AND I'M GONNA
TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY IN THIS
STYLE OR APPEARANCE TONIGHT TO
REMIND PEOPLE WHO THE
CONSERVATIVES ARE PURE WE LOVE
EVERYBODY APPEARED WE PEOPLE.
WE SEE I SEE A POTENTIAL AS WE
LOOK OUT OVER THE COUNTRY.
WE WANT PEOPLE TO BE THE BEST
THEY CAN BE.
WE WANT PEOPLE TO BE HAPPY.
WE REALIZE WHAT A BLESSED
OPPORTUNITY IT IS TO BE BORN IN
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA AND
WE WANT EVERYBODY TO MAXIMIZE
THEIR POTENTIAL BECAUSE THAT'S
HOW YOU GET A GATE GREAT COUNTRY
GREAT IS HOW YOU GET GREAT
INNERVATION, THAT'S HOW YOU GET
GREAT MODERNIZATION, GREAT MILIT
GREAT MODERNIZATION, GREAT MILIR
GREAT MODERNIZATION, GREAT MILI,
GREAT ANYTHING.
GREAT PEOPLE.
IT'S THE PEOPLE OF THIS COUNTRY
WHO MAKE IT WORK.
NOW, THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY,
THAT'S JUST A FOREIGN LANGUAGE
TO THEM.
THOSE KIND OF PEOPLE STOP AND
THINK, THOSE PEOPLE ARE OF NO
USE TO THE DEMOCRATS.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE THREATENED BY
PEOPLE WHO CAN RELY ON
THEMSELVES.
THEY ARE THREATENED BY PEOPLE
WHO CAN TAKE CARE OF THEMSELVES.
BECAUSE THOSE PEOPLE ARE NOT
DEPENDENT.
THOSE PEOPLE ARE NOT GOING TO BE
IN NEED.
THOSE PEOPLE AND ARE RUNNING
AROUND TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHO
IT IS THAT IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
THEIR UNHAPPINESS AND THEIR
MISERY.
THEY ARE TOO BUSY TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THE BLESSED
OPPORTUNITY TO LIVE IN THIS
COUNTRY AND NOT EVERYBODY IS BUT
THE POINT IS, WE HAVE FREEDOM TO
BE AND DO WHATEVER WE WANT.
THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO PUT
OBSTACLES IN PEOPLE'S WAY.
THE LEFT WANTS TO SHACKLE
PEOPLE.
THEY DON'T BELIEVE IN PEOPLE.
THEY DON'T BELIEVE IN FREEDOM
AND LIBERTY BECAUSE THEY DON'T
TRUST PEOPLE.
THEY THINK MOST PEOPLE ARE
DECRYPTED AND DISHONEST AND
RACIST, SEXIST, BIGOTED
HOMOPHOBES.
I DON'T KNOW HOW IN THE WORLD
ANYBODY ON THAT SIDE THINGS THAT
THEY ARE GOING TO PUT TOGETHER A
MAJORITY TO WIN A NATIONAL
ELECTION WITH THAT KIND OF AN
AGENDA.
ANYONE THAT THINKS AMERICA IS
NOT GREAT, NOT EXCEPTIONAL,
UNMORAL OR UNJUST, HOW DO YOU
>> Sean: WE NOW CONTINUE ON
THE 31ST ANNIVERSARY OF THE RUSH
LIMBAUGH SHOW.
RUSH LIMBAUGH, WE TALKED ABOUT
THIS PHENOMENON WHERE PEOPLE
WILL WAIT IN THE POURING RAIN 20
HOURS TO SEE DONALD TRUMP.
>> THAT'S BECAUSE TRUMP APPEALS
TO PEOPLE IN A WAY THAT I JUST
TALKED ABOUT.
HE APPEALS TO PEOPLE'S BUT HER
INTEREST.
THIS IS WHAT PEOPLE DON'T
UNDERSTAND ABOUT ALL TRUMP HAD
TO GET CAUGHT UP IN THE WEEDS,
THEY GET CAUGHT UP IN ALL THE
MANNERS AND YET THE MAN TOUCHES
EVERYBODY'S HEARTS, TALKING
ABOUT GREATNESS, TALKING ABOUT
INSPIRATION AND ASPIRATIONAL
LIVING, BEING GREAT.
EVERYBODY WANTS THAT.
EVERYBODY WANTS TO IMPROVE THEIR
LIVES AND THEIR FAMILIES FOR
THEM SELF.
HE TOUCHES ME, HE'S GOT A BOND
WITH HIS VOTERS THAT NOBODY CAN
BREAK.
HE'S GOT A BOND THAT IS INNATE.
NOT EVERYBODY CAN CREATE THIS
BOND.
IT IS NOT A DEMOCRAT ON THAT
STAGE EITHER NIGHT THAT HAS ANY
KIND OF A BOND WITH ANYBODY IN
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
TRUMP IS UNTOUCHABLE.
THERE'S NOT ONE PERSON ON THE
DEMOCRATIC STAGE THE LAST TWO
NIGHTS THAT I CAN EVEN BE ON
STAGE WITH TRUMP AND NOT BE
OVERSHADOWED BY HIS PRESENCE.
>> Sean: BUT STILL, RUSH, WE
FOLLOW ELECTIONS.
THIS IS OUR LIFE.
THIS IS WHAT WE DO.
FOR ANY REPUBLICAN TO WIN THE
PRESIDENCY, THEY ALWAYS HAVE TO
THREAD THE NEEDLE.
FLORIDA, NORTH CAROLINA,
MARK MEADOWS STATE, OHIO, YOU'VE
GOT TO PICK OFF, AND MICHIGAN,
PENNSYLVANIA, IT'S NOT EVER
GOING TO BE EASY AND THERE'S
ALWAYS THAT APPEAL, OLD, WE WILL
TAKE ALL OF YOUR FEAR WAY AND
EVERYTHING WILL BE TAKEN CARE
OF.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, I GUESS MAYBE
I'VE BEEN AT THIS FOR SO LONG
AND I DO HAVE TO REMIND MYSELF
THAT THEY HAVE A LOT OF
SUPPORTERS.
THAT'S ONE OF THE SCARY THINGS.
YOU WATCH THE DEBATE LAST NIGHT
AND YOU HEAR THIS LUNACY.
IT WAS LUNACY.
IT WAS GENUINE -- GO IF YOU CAN
DEFINE NORMALCY IN ANY WHICH WAY
WE HAVE IN COMMON COME THOSE
PEOPLE ARE LUNATICS.
AND THEN YOU REALIZE, THAT
PEOPLE AREN'T PLOTTING IT.
I WAS WORRIED ABOUT A 20 YEARS
AGO WHEN PEOPLE WOULD LAUGH AND
NOBODY'S EVER GOING TO BELIEVE
THAT THEY SAID.
AND NOW, HERE WE ARE.
I DO BELIEVE IT.
I UNDERSTAND THE THREAT HERE.
AND LET ME GIVE AN EXAMPLE OF
WHERE I THINK WE HAVE A GOLDEN
OPPORTUNITY.
TULSI GABBARD CAME OUT OF
NOWHERE LAST NIGHT BECAUSE SHE
REAMED KAMALA HARRIS.
NOW, WHAT IS THE MEDIA DOING
TODAY?
I LOVE THIS.
GUESS WHAT?
TO EXPLAIN TULSI GABBARD, THEY
ARE SAYING THAT SHE'S ACTUALLY
WORKING WITH THE RUSSIANS WHO
ARE STILL WORKING WITH TRUMP AND
OUR GAME PLAN IS TO BECOME A
THIRD-PARTY INDEPENDENT
CANDIDATE TO SPLIT THE
DEMOCRATIC VOTE.
THEY STARTED THIS RUSSIAN
INSANITY AND NOW THEY ARE WEDDED
TO IT.
THEY CAN'T LET IT GO OF IT.
AND THERE'S NOTHING IN IT FOR
THEM ON THIS.
THERE IS NO WINNING WITH IT I
DON'T BELIEVE.
NOW, I'M NOT A POLITICAL
PROFESSIONAL.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THREADING
THE NEEDLE IN ALL OF THESE DAYS,
I JUST SAY, JUST HAVE TRUMP EACH
ON.
JUST APPEAL TO PEOPLE AND THEIR
BETTER INTEREST AND HE CAN
PERMEATE THIS NOISE LIKE HE DID
IN 2016.
>> Sean: THREE WORDS I WANT TO
THROW AT YOU.
AGREE NEW DEAL.
>> WELL, IT'S A TRICK.
THE GREEN DEAL, EVEN
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO CORTEZ, HER
CHIEF OF STAFF, ADMITTED THAT
IT'S NOT ABOUT THE CLIMATE.
IT'S NOT ABOUT THE WEATHER.
IT'S AN ECONOMIC PLAN.
AND IT IS.
IT'S DESIGNED TO GET MASSIVE
FEDERAL POWER, GROW THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, UNDER THE PRETENSE
THAT AVERAGE AMERICANS CANNOT BE
LEFT TO LIVE THEIR LIVES WITHOUT
RUINING THINGS, ESPECIALLY IN
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
IT'S UNAFFORDABLE, IT WILL NEVER
HAPPEN, AND THE PREMISE BEHIND
IT IS BOGUS.
THERE IS NO MAN MADE IT CLIMATE
CHANGE.
THERE IS NOTHING WE CAN DO TO
STOP WHATEVER THE WEATHER IS
GOING TO DO.
WE CAN MAKE IT WARMER, WE CAN'T
MAKE IT COLDER.
WE CAN'T CHANGE HURRICANES
DIRECTIONS, WE CAN ANTICIPATE
THEM.
WE CAN'T CREATE THEM.
AND YET, THEY ARE CAMPAIGNING
AND TRYING TO GIVE THE PEOPLE, I
MEAN, LOOK AT MILLENNIALS.
IT'S REALLY SAD IT IS A LOT OF
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO REALLY THINK
THIS PLAN IS NOT GOING TO BE
HABITABLE BY THE TIME I HIT 65.
THESE PEOPLE ARE RUINING
PEOPLE'S LIVES.
THERE RUINING THEIR FUTURES ALL
IN PURSUIT OF POWER FOR
THEMSELVES.
IT'S DISGUSTING ON A LEVEL TO
ME.
AND I THINK WE NEED TO BE CALLED
OUT AND I THINK THIS STUFF NEEDS
TO BE SAID POINT BLANK TO THEM
BECAUSE THE MEDIA IT IS NOT
GOING TO DO IT.
THE MEDIA IS THEIR BEST BUDDIES
AND A SUPPORT GROUP.
IT'S A BIG BATTLE.
I'M JUST OPTIMISTIC THAT I'M
CONFIDENT THAT THESE PEOPLE CAN
BE BEAT BECAUSE THEY ARE GETTING
NUTTIER AND NUTTIER EVERY DAY.
THEY ARE DEM
>> Sean: AS I CONTINUE,
JOINING US, THE RUSH LIMBAUGH.
31 YEARS BROADCAST EXCELLENCE.
THIS IS A MILESTONE.
I REMEMBER WHEN I FIRST HEARD
ABOUT YOU, I WAS --
I STARTED IN RADIO 1987.
I WAS IN A COLLEGE RADIO STATIO
RADIO STATION.
THIS GUY COMES UP TO ME AND SAYS
HAVE YOU EVER HEARD OF THE SKY
RUSH LIMBAUGH?
YOU CREATED A HUGE FIRE STORM
OUT THERE IN SAN FRANCISCO.
IT WAS A BARBECUE PLACE A
BOYCOTT OF YOU AND YOU SENT ALL
OF YOUR LISTENERS INTO THE
BARBECUE PLACE AND THEY CAME
BACK.
SO, 31 YEARS, IT'S AMAZING
ACCOMPLISHMENT AND YOU ARE RIGH
RIGHT.
>> YOU ARE ONE OF MY FIRST GUEST
HOST, SEAN.
WE KIND OF BEEN IN THIS
TOGETHER.
WE'VE BEEN CONNECTED SINCE THIS
ALL STARTED.
IT'S --
LOOK GOOD I KNOW TIME IS LIMITED
HERE.
SOMETIMES PEOPLE ACCUSE ME OF
BEING A LITTLE TOO POLLYANNAISH
AND NOT AWARE OF SOME OF THE
PITFALLS YOU SAY, THREADING THE
NEEDLE.
I'M NOT NAIVE.
I KNOW HOW DIFFICULT IT IS.
I'M NOT TRYING TO CLAIM THIS IS
GOING TO BE EASY.
I WANT PEOPLE TO LOOK AT THE
DEMOCRATS.
I'M SICK AND TIRED OF BEING
AFRAID OF THESE PEOPLE GET I'M
SICK AND TIRED OF PEOPLE ACTING
INTIMIDATED BY DEMOCRATS,
ESPECIALLY THIS CURRENT CROP.
THERE IS NO REASON TO FEAR THESE
PEOPLE.
I KNOW THEY HAVE THE MEDIA ON
THEIR SIDE.
DONALD TRUMP DOESN'T FEAR THEM.
DONALD TRUMP DOESN'T LET THEM
INTIMIDATE HIM.
DONALD TRUMP IS SHOWING HOW
PEOPLE ON OUR SIDE CAN WIN FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN MANY, MANY
YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN DOING THIS.
HE IS SHOWING PEOPLE EVERY DAY
HOW TO WIN AND THERE IS AN ART
TO KNOWING HOW TO WIN, NOT JUST
PLAYING THE GAMES AND NOT BEING
ON THE STAGE.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE MAKING
THEMSELVES GIGANTIC TARGETS TO
THIS RUSSIA THING.
IT'S BLOWN UP IN THEIR FACE.
THE MEDIA IS NOT TELLING
ANYBODY, BUT IT HAS.
THEY'VE GOT NOTHING.
ALL THE LAWSUITS ARE BEING
THROWN OUT NOW.
COLIN WAS THROWN OUT, THERE IS
NOTHING.
WE'VE BEEN IN A RACE.
THIS IS BUT CALL ME, I KNOW
EVERYBODY IS UPSET AND IT LOOKS
LIKE HOME HE IS GOING TO WALK.
I HAVE FAITH.
I FAITH THAT THE PEOPLE DOING
THIS INVESTIGATION ARE GOING TO
HOLD THESE PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE.
FOR THREE YEARS, TWO YEARS,
WE'VE BEEN HEARING THAT ALL OF
THIS IS GOING TO COME TO
FRUITION AND A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
FRUSTRATED, DISAPPOINTED.
THEY WERE TODAY WHEN IT WAS SAID
TO CALL ME IS NOT GOING TO BE
PROSECUTED FOR ALL REASONS
BECAUSE HE DIDN'T INTEND TO DO
IT.
THERE HAS TO BE ACCOUNTABILITY
HERE.
AND I THINK THAT IT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN AT GREAT TIMING FOR THE
2020 ELECTION.
LET'S JUST SEE.
>> Sean: I AGREE WITH ALL
THAT.
I ACTUALLY SEE SIMILARITIES
BETWEEN YOU AND TRON.
LET ME TELL YOU WHAT TWO OF THEM
ARE.
NUMBER ONE, YOU'VE GOT TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE A PUNCH.
YOU PAVED THE WAY FOR A LOT OF
US THAT OUR CONSERVATIVES IN THE
MEDIA.
YOU HAVE TAKEN MORE THAN YOUR
FAIR SHARE.
AND THEN, YOU'VE GOT TO FIGHT
FOR WHAT YOU BELIEVE.
MY BIGGEST CRITICISM CRITICISM
OF REPUBLICANS IS THAT THEY ARE
WEAK, A LOT OF THEM, AND TIMID
AND AFRAID TO DO WHAT YOU DO
EVERY DAY.
TO DO WHAT TRUMP IS DOING.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
SHOWING THEM THE WAY.
JUST FIGHT FOR WHAT YOU SAY YOU
WERE GOING FIGHT FOR.
>> WELL, LOOK.
THEY'RE TWO DIFFERENT THINGS
GOING ON.
I DON'T HAVE TO GET VOTES.
YOU AND I CAN SUCCEED WITH
PEOPLE HATING US.
OR DISLIKING US.
>> Sean: THERE'S A LOT OF
THEM, RUSH.
>> PEOPLE WHO NEED TO WIN
ELECTIONS, PEOPLE THAT DON'T
LIKE HIM DON'T VOTE FOR HIM.
SO I UNDERSTAND THEIR REASONS
FOR BUT I THINK I CAN BE
OVERCOME WITH ATTITUDE AND
CONFIDENCE.
THIS FEAR OF BEING CALLED A
RACIST, EVERYONE NEEDS TO GET
OVER THAT NOW BECAUSE ALL OF US
ARE RACIST.
EVERYBODY'S RACES.
THEY CAN'T TALK ABOUT ANY BUDDY
NOW WITHOUT LABELING THEM AS
RACIST.
THIS THING THAT TRUMPED IT ABOUT
BALTIMORE, IT'S ABOUT TIME THIS
STUFF IS CALLED OUT.
THE DEMOCRATS RUN CITIES OR
ASTOUNDS OR STAY, WITH ONE PARTY
RULE, THOSE PLACES ARE SUFFERING
GREATLY.
THE PEOPLE THEY ARE SUFFERING.
DRUG ADDICTION, THEIR SUFFERING
JUG INFESTATION AND THEY ARE
SUFFERING FILTH AND NOBODY EVER
CALLS THEM OUT ON IT BECAUSE YOU
CAN'T BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATS
SUPPOSEDLY ARE THE ONES WITH
COMPASSION SO YOU CAN CRITICIZE
THEM.
THE HECK WITH THAT.
THEY DESERVE TO BE CRITICIZED.
THEY DESERVE TO BE CALLED OUT.
IT WAS CUMMINGS AND HIMSELF 20
YEARS AGO.
EVERYBODY SEEN THE VIDEO NOW,
WHO REFERRED HIS OWN CITY AS
DRUG-INFESTED AND NOBODY SAID IT
WAS RACIST BACK THEN.
TRUMP IS REALLY SHOWING A LOT OF
PEOPLE HOW TO TAKE THESE PEOPLE
ON.
YOU KNOW, WE'VE GOT THIS
NEVER TRUMPER PROBLEM THAT I
THINK IS KIND OF LIKE AN
ELEPHANT OR A FLY ON AN ELEPHAN
ELEPHANT'S SPLIT PEOPLE MAKE IT
OUT TO BE BIGGER THAN IT IS
BECAUSE THESE WERE SUPPOSEDLY
THE INTELLECTUAL LEADERS OF OUR
PARTY.
THEY'VE BEEN RENDERED IRRELEVANT
COULD THEY KNOW IT.
THEY ARE PROBABLY GOING TO A
VOTE DEMOCRAT IF THEY HAD A
CHANCE SIMPLY BECAUSE, HOW ARE
THEY GOING TO SELL CRUISES NOW?
FOR 20 YEARS, THEY THOUGHT THEY
WERE THE INTELLECTUAL LEADERS OF
CONSERVATISM AND THEY NEVER GOT
MUCH DONE.
I KNOW WE ARE OUT OF TIME.
I'M SORRY.
I LIKE BEING HERE.
>> Sean: I SHOULD HAVE JUST
GIVEN YOU THE WHOLE HOUR.
31 YEARS.
I JUST WANT TO TELL PEOPLE 15.
WHEN YOU STARTED IN SYNDICATION,